hello everyone I promise it's nearly
over in 2016 this incredibly talented
woman made history as the first female
artistic director in its 70 year history
then she took feminism to the front row
with her first collection and made
headlines around the world
there were romantic gowns and bold logo
underwear but the PS de resistance was
her we should all be feminists PETA
taken from the title after Amanda and
Gozo Adichie's celebrated TED talk
let us honor a woman who celebrates
individuality and personality who in her
own word said there is not only one
story she's the woman fashion needs
absolutely right now it's glamorous
designer of the year Maria gratia Curie
I'd like to thank soliciting the readers
of glamour and the John Calvin for this
very special work it is an order to
assess it and I'm very touched by all
your support it is amazing for me to see
James Corden on the cover of the
magazine wearing the wishes be feminist
t-shirts for my first collection for the
earth thank you John for this idea and
thank you James
for being BAE and asked to wear it I'd
also like to thank my daughter who is
here with me tonight this award is for
our generation and their concern is per
me in my work thank you